Hey,
what's going on and spill?
Burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast in jazz jacket.
Yay.
You.
How is your week going?
Is it going well?
I am in gloomy,
rainy,
Vancouver,
British Columbia,
home of the BC lions,
the Vancouver Canucks and no fucking Westminster dog show.
Got Unless someplace out here at Westminster.
And I learned today that they do have a big dog show up here,
but I don't think they are one in the same.
I can't remember if Westminster takes place in Beverly Hills
or in New York City,
but all I know is that you have to be a particular level white person to be
invited.
I learned that because I thought I was white enough,
you know,
and they were like,
oh no,
you are not.
And uh,
my dream of attending it,
it was over.
Um,
I just think it's funny.
I like dogs.
And then it's just funny when they get them on,
like,
you know,
all shampooed up and that Princeton around,
and I dunno,
there's always like that thought of what if the owner false just adds to the
tension,
you know?
Um,
anyways,
I'm up here in Vancouver,
I'm having a great time.
Uh,
this past weekend I went to a wedding,
uh,
awesome wedding,
tremendous wedding.
Two people that should be getting married.
They totally had the connection.
Is there anything worse unless you just really into shied Freud?
Um,
when you go to a wedding and you just see two people and you're like,
this fucking thing is not going to last the weekend.
I've been to two of those and one of them,
the marriage lasted two years maybe.
And then the other one,
as far as I know,
they're still together.
Um,
the first weird wedding that I went to,
yeah,
I think the bride was having second thoughts because the groom was standing up
there forever
and then she just showed her walk down the halls,
walked on down the hall,
right.
Walk down the aisle with their dad
and did not have that look that,
you know,
somebody usually has on their wedding day.
Um,
and then when she went up to the altar the whole time they were doing the vows,
she was laughing uncontrollably,
um,
which is,
you know,
sometimes it's just a form of nervousness,
but,
uh,
they didn't even kiss.
And as they walked out,
they went ahead and kiss.
But uh,
as far as I know,
they're still together.
And then another one was,
uh,
someone I was in business with when I first got in to New York City and I went
to this person's wedding and I remember we went out there
and,
uh,
the mother in law,
we got there like what was traffic when we got there right before the wedding
was going to start,
it was in the backyard of these rich people's,
uh,
state,
right?
This guy married into money and he wasn't rich,
so I think they didn't like him.
So she was,
we pulled up,
she was outside walking the dog dressed the way you would walk a dog.
Like she wasn't really even ready.
It was like sort of this nonverbal protest of what was going on in there and uh,
okay.
That seemed weird.
I was like,
well,
you know,
the inlaws usually never liked the fucking person that daughters daughter's and
they never think that these good enough.
Right.
So it didn't really,
you know,
it wasn't much of a red flag.
But then I just remembered when,
uh,
the groom afterwards they got married,
he went to uh,
give a toast as to why he loved his wife and it was fucking brutal.
He was like,
uh,
she,
cause she gave some big toast to him.
So then he goes,
okay,
and Dan to you,
my lovely wife,
you,
uh,
you make me laugh.
Uh,
where the background like lighter your life reason you get up in the morning,
like trying to help him out.
It was one of those things where everyone was smiling like this is going to be
great.
And then it just became like everyone just sort of looking down going,
dude,
wrap it up,
wrap it up.
And that one lasted like two years and it was such a fucked up marriage.
Okay.
I remember him telling me
that they just had this big fight and they were both kind of exhausted
and one of them was just kinda like,
what are we doing?
And the other one who was just like,
yeah,
do you like not want to do this anymore?
And the other one was like,
no.
And then the other one was like,
really?
Because I don't either.
And then they started laughing like a bad fucking movie and they had a really
Amy,
a couple divorce.
And I think he was cool.
He didn't try to take any of her fucking money and they just went their separate
ways.
They haven't said that this wedding that I went to,
I always have that in the back of my head because as much as I like to do
standup,
I don't literally like to be living in a bit when I'm at a wedding,
you know?
Um,
I don't know.
I just saw him interacting right before the wedding and you know,
it's super stressful if you've ever gotten married and they just seem chill and
relax.
So it was like,
oh good,
good.
Um,
what was funny about this wedding was there was also another ball git Ya at the
wedding with a red beard,
like my doppelganger.
And um,
I went there and I had a drink and then I had another drink and then I was just
like,
Eh,
you know,
that's good.
I'm going to stop there.
And I started drinking water.
Now on the other hand,
the other guy was acting like me last year.
Well before I took four months off of drinking and this fucking guy got fucking
loaded,
right?
So I saw he was kind of swaying in the breeze and I'm like,
Oh,
you know,
Ben there,
I'm not going to judge.
He's having a good time,
whatever.
Right?
So the fucking guy.
Next thing I know,
I'm looking outside
and this guy like this wedding was so perfect,
was in this really cool restaurant and slash bar and so up front was the bar and
they had these ceiling to floor windows and the evil version of me at some
points staggered outside and I just felt everybody looking and they looked any
just fucking puked in the street in front of like a third of the wedding was up
at the bar,
like a giant puddle of puke.
So all his friends rush outside and that fucking suits to help about and
somebody brought a chair out.
Well they sit the guy down and I'm not laughing at the guy,
I'm just laughing because I've been there.
I mean that in a fucking,
not having to all wedding that I was just at looking at me,
but you know,
we've all had our moments.
I remember one time I was somewhere down the Cape Fucking Cape Cod Jode best
fucking potato chips.
Okay.
I somehow passed out on a bluff that was headed down towards the ocean.
I was just like the middle of the day
and uh,
I forget where my buddy was.
He was the one driving,
he was somewhere somewhere else.
I came home,
something happened with the car,
um,
and we were just passed out.
I'm like,
the fucking this,
it was a bluff fight.
I just like saying that word.
I've never used it properly.
And all of a sudden I was laying there and the son felt good and everything I
was passed out and like it felt like a day later,
all of a sudden I just here and out there,
that is where the Nina,
the Pinta and it picked up in the Santa Maria came in back in 14 fucking blah
blah,
blah.
And then I had this little kid's voice go,
Mommy,
why is that guy sleeping there?
And there was like some sort of fucking tour going on
and a,
I vaguely remember changing a tire and I didn't put the Jack Underneath the
frame and it went to like rush through the floorboard.
So there you go.
All right.
I'm not judging this guy,
but it was funny as fucking hell.
So this fucking guy fucking just,
you know,
Great Lakes Yak,
puke all over the streets or somebody brings a chair out and they sit them down
and he's sitting there hanging his head.
Like,
you know,
Jordan was sitting when he had the flu and they put the towel over his head.
He was sitting like that minus the towel over his head.
So then they start calling like an Uber or Lyft and these cars keep pulling up
and they pull up to this bald dude with the red beard sitting with his head
hanging down in a giant puddle of puke.
And everybody would just pull out and be like,
yeah,
it's fucking,
guy's not getting my car.
They would drive away.
And,
uh,
it just became this thing like,
dude,
you gotta move up down the street.
You got to get them away from the puke.
And Anyway,
somebody finally came along and took them home.
But,
uh,
he was definitely the highlight of the evening.
So,
uh,
I want to,
I don't know who that guy was,
but I want to thank him for the,
uh,
the free entertainment.
So anyways,
let's get back on track here.
I'm up here in our Vancouver and uh,
as I mentioned before,
I don't know if I mentioned,
uh,
I was talking to a number of people up here that listen to this podcast to fly
helicopters and one of them had access to the,
uh,
Cabri g two.
I hope I'm saying that right cabaret or is it [inaudible]?
I think it's Cabri g two,
which is basically like the Robinson r 22 that I fly.
But it has,
you know,
any safety issues that the Robinson may or may not have,
that it does have,
I'm just not trying to shit on it because I fly it all the time and I do like
that helicopter.
These people took it to the next level.
It's like the next iPhone,
except it didn't try to like,
you know,
capture your fucking face.
Um,
it was new and improved,
so I wanted to try this thing out and um,
these people had access to it.
So I was going to rent a car today and his drive about an hour outside of
Vancouver.
Um,
but then I got a text from the guy who was going to fly with said,
hey,
there's a guy here,
he's a big fan of yours.
He's got a fucking the,
he's got a 66,
I'll pick you up right at the heliport downtown.
I was like,
fuck it,
let's do it.
So I show up,
this dude named Chris,
I want to thank him.
Great guy picked me up a me all the way out there and I was telling him,
he goes,
so how did you get into wanting to fly?
Uh,
the Cabri g two?
And I was like,
well,
you know,
I read all about,
the low,
Geez,
you know,
situations,
the mass bumping.
I got a little freaked out.
Vietnam helicopter pilots.
I just kind of feel like it's a bit of a safety issue and they just sort of
taught pilots how to fly out of it rather than fix it.
But what the fuck do I know?
I only have 160 hours.
Right.
But that was just my gut feeling.
So I want to check this thing out to see what the deals with this thing.
So we land at the airport and as we land one of those Cabri g tubes is coming in
and I immediately loved it.
I loved the shape of it.
And when it landed,
seeing this little two seater with the fully articulated main rotor system was
like,
I mean that's,
that's been the dream.
Um,
you know,
cause with the art 22 you got to lead with the collective with,
with those things,
you can just push the stick forward,
which,
uh,
it's still,
whenever I,
something like that,
when the guy just goes,
okay,
knows it forward,
I always have to make the joke that,
you know,
I usually don't hear that,
flying a Robinson.
So anyways,
um,
okay.
The thing lands and as it lands,
I see this guy getting out who looks just like the dude that I saw on the
youtube video and I was like that the guy who uploaded the video that did the
whole,
okay,
the whole thing from nose to tail review of it,
he goes,
yeah,
that's him.
And it was so surreal because I didn't know I was going to meet this guy.
It was like literally the guy that was the reason that I wanted to fly it.
I ended up not only going to his place,
I ended up getting a fly with them.
Uh,
it's BC helicopters and the guy's name is Misha Gilb and he was incredible
pilot.
He did an auto rotation at the end.
That was just was unreal for those of you who fly Robinson's,
there's no watching your rpms going too high,
too low.
It's just teach us,
put the collective down and steer it.
And he landed this thing like,
like,
like a fucking daisy.
It was incredible.
And um,
so anyways,
he,
he was filming the entire time that we were flying and um,
I was flying horribly.
I could barely even,
I couldn't even hold the hover in the thing because the main road,
it turned the exact opposite way.
And as much as I told myself,
ignore your muscle memory,
just,
you know,
correct.
Whichever way the nose is going.
And it was also super sensitive.
It felt like the sports suspension on a car,
like a sports car,
you know?
MMM.
Where it was so hypersensitive that I just kept over correcting.
And then it was,
it took me back to when I had like under 10 hours
flying and was just the first time trying to hold the hover.
But,
uh,
of course,
by the end I got way better than where I was at,
but by then his GoPro had ran out.
So you can guys can have a fun time laughing at me flying this thing like a
fucking salmon going up seats upstream.
It was pretty bad in the beginning,
but,
um,
I really,
really loved it and I got to fly,
you know,
I mean,
it was definitely a cloudy day and everything,
but I thought it was kind of cool that it was raining out and all that just to
flying something different and,
um,
got to go all along the,
uh,
the whole skyline of Vancouver,
all the way up to where all these rich people live and shit.
And then,
uh,
we flew back and on the way back we flew up this river bed,
which I hope he keeps that footage.
That's one of the coolest things I ever did.
MMM.
I felt like I was on the discovery channel.
Like I should have been chasing a bunch of gazelles or something or watching
hippos,
you know,
fighting alligators.
There's something out on the Serengeti.
It was amazing.
And,
um,
we ended up landing off airport up there.
We landed off airport and,
uh,
just some farmer's yard.
And that's when I was just like,
I had it.
The thing was all over the place when I was flying.
Um,
but anyways,
I just want to thank everybody at BC helicopters.
I S I had such a great time and I will definitely be back and a,
for those of you who do fly,
so you get a chance to check out one of those calves,
Eg to sip,
pretty fucking amazing.
Um,
and uh,
and that's it.
And then I got two more shows tonight at the Queen Elizabeth Theater here.
And,
um,
and then I immediately go back to go hang with the family because that's the new
me,
right?
I fly in the day of the Gig and then I do the Gig the next day and then I
immediately leave because I got my,
you know,
my lovely wife and my daughter.
I gotta go,
I gotta get home too.
So if I only leave for like two days,
I don't have that much guilt.
Well,
you feel like an absentee absentee father,
you know.
Um,
so anyways,
um,
what time do we got here?
Yes.
15 minutes.
And I should probably do this.
Read here.
Okay.
Me undies,
everybody.
All right.
You heard me talk about me on these and you know that I am a big believer in
their product.
They're the perfect balance of comfortable fit every month they have new and
exciting prints and they arrive at your door in a fun bag.
Now when I was a kid,
that was a term for titties.
Hey look,
a little fun bags on that bird.
Um,
so I guess they ride it,
ride in a fund back me undies uses a lady me undies.
Uses Lens Zig Micro Modal,
modal,
and they'll Calibri Calibri and their underwear.
It's sustainably sourced naturally soft fiber that starts with beechwood trees.
The underwear is made out of trees and ends with the most amazing fabric you've
ever experienced.
The results have been downright dreamy.
Oh,
thank God.
I wouldn't want to pet my ball.
Bay gets stabbed with a splitter.
Me undies is so sure you'll love their underwear.
They offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee.
If you don't love your first pair it you get a full refund.
That's a no brainer.
Get 20% off a pair of the most comfortable undies that you will ever put on.
Fuck.
I get to a sentence to get your 20% off your first pair of free shipping and
100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to me undies.com/ [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash burr.
All right,
let's take a second to talk about the fucking Oscar.
Um,
congratulations to everyone who was nominated and everybody who won,
but in particular two people,
one,
I don't know if you were paying attention,
but two people that won an Oscar on Monday.
Also do a voice on the wonderful cartoon after Easter family,
Allison Janney who did the voice of Ah,
Mrs Plaster where uh,
she won an Oscar for the Tonya Harding movie.
And then Sam Rockwell who does the voice of a Frank's nemesis,
even though he does,
he's not even aware that he's this number assist Vic Reynolds one for three
billboards.
Um,
so that's pretty cool.
You know,
I think that upped the ante of our show.
The status anyways
too.
I know,
I'm throwing that in.
Who Does your show?
Who Do you do with your show was Oh,
two Oscar winners.
Allison Janney and Sam Rockwell.
Right.
Laura dern,
Justin Long.
Dave Kepner.
I'm and I can go on forever.
Um,
by the way,
I'm really loving the,
I don't want to jinx it,
but this season three,
I know I'm teasing it early,
but uh,
we've been laughing our asses off in the,
uh,
the edit room.
But I got to tell you yesterday I came in,
landed and I was really tired because I did a show the night before to a four
show us show down at the Improv.
And
I had a beer or two after at the end of the,
um,
at the end of the show and he didn't get home til like,
you know,
one in the morning or something like that.
And then my daughter,
my daughter gets up at like quarter to six,
six o'clock.
It's hilarious.
You know,
just come downstairs.
He can't,
you know,
isn't that this point?
Like the reason why I drink so little now is now I don't know what happened.
Like if I have like,
like one beer or two beers,
like the next day,
you know,
my daughter wakes me up and it's just like,
I feel it's some
waking up just not like a hung over but just feeling like less energized
and you know,
she's talking all this jibberish out there and I just opened the door and the
second I opened the door she just goes,
hi.
I don't know if I told you,
it's like high is her word for everything.
High means high.
High means I want that.
Or if she wants attention,
she does like this frantic like hi.
Hi.
Like,
if she sees two people talking and she wants to be is to really like her being
like,
hey,
little help over here.
Um,
I want to get out of this fucking chair.
So,
um,
anyway,
so I didn't get a lot of sleep and then I had to go to the airport and then I
flew up and whenever you flying the plane this way,
so he's like,
everybody wants to sleep except for that one person who has the window open and
then I can't fall asleep.
So I get to the hotel and I'm like,
all right,
now I'm just going to lay down here for like a half an hour.
And I had south park on speaking of,
you know,
animated shows,
just total next level.
Absolutely fucking hilarious.
And I was watching this episode where Cartman had stolen a bunch of votes
and uh,
I fell asleep and I woke up a little later and I open my eyes and South Park was
still on.
I didn't realize that they had a marathon going on,
like they did like three or four episodes in a row.
A long story short,
my pickup for the seven o'clock show is it's six 20 and I am asleep and all of a
sudden the phone rings super loud in my room and I open my eyes and it's pitch
black in the room.
And I was like,
Oh fuck.
And I was trying to find my way out and I couldn't,
I literally opened the door that went into a closet and then verse he called me
and I saw it.
It was six 30.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
I literally just threw my clothes on,
didn't even iron my shirt,
got to the venue,
sipped a little stroke OT and went out on stage.
Had a great set though,
but I was like really?
A,
it was weird.
I was like,
okay,
I wasn't tired cause I slept for like three hours.
So I felt refreshed.
But I also felt like I just woke up.
So,
um,
I dunno if the first 10 minutes the show felt like an outer body experience,
but,
uh,
I've never slept like,
like that close up until like almost like missing a show or something like that.
But,
uh,
fortunately,
you know,
went well.
I don't know that kind of went nowhere.
You know,
I almost missed my show but I didn't.
And then the show went well like did I really need to fucking tell you all of
that?
Was there a reason for that?
I apologize that this recording sucks.
I bought at an external mic for my iPhone that uh,
Kevin Shea,
the hilarious Kevin Shay came on my show.
That's right.
It came on the Monday morning podcast,
promoted his special and told me all about this.
Mike going,
I love this fucking microphone.
I'm gonna have to talk to him about it cause I ordered it off the Internet
there,
the inner web and uh,
it was only 20 bucks.
I'm like,
how the fuck is a microphone that only costs $20 going to be good?
And guess what?
It isn't.
It fucking sucks.
So I must be using it wrong.
Cause Kevin Shay's is smart guy so he's got to teach me how to use the fucking
thing.
Cause it sounds worse than if I just hold the phone up like I am right now,
if that makes any sense.
Okay.
But anyways,
I,
oh my God,
I have to tell you this fucking stupid tee shirt that I saw there.
There's like some corporation up here,
you know,
selling clothes.
One of those,
one of those fucking closed the place and on the mannequins they have all this
fucking political tee shirts about equal pay for women.
And it says like,
enough is enough and something about a quality and all that.
And it's just like,
I just can't like
these fucking assholes.
It's like you were,
the guy's not fucking paying people.
Like,
why am I getting a fucking leg?
My voice cracking it.
What the fuck are you?
Okay.
How do you get off selling those fucking shirts?
I don't understand why these feminist groups don't go in there and be like,
okay,
you're selling enough is enough.
T shirts,
uh,
why you sell it?
Well,
let's look into your fucking history of,
of paying people that's like this new,
this new fucking thing.
What it is,
it's not a new thing.
This is what people always do when a movement happens and they get freaked out
by what they eventually do is they join it and once they join it they have like
a level of control or they could just act like they fucking agree with it.
So then like you don't,
nobody's looking at you like you're a problem.
You basically you just cut,
sort of send it down the line like no problem.
Here look we have uh,
enough is enough t shirts.
Um,
I actually have an uh,
an enough is enough thing,
uh,
enough is enough as far as just going after what guys do to women.
How about we balanced it out,
you know,
and some on all this shit that fucker women do to guys,
you know.
Ah,
that'll never happen.
you can't do that.
If you do that then you're a fucking sexist.
We're going to six,
the male female dynamic by only examining the behavior of men
because the ladies are perfect.
I would love to know what sweatshop makes those enough is enough.
T shirts,
what do fuck is Michael Moore lately?
Well,
actually,
it's a tee shirt sold here in Canada and God knows he blows everybody north of
fucking Minnesota.
He just thinks that,
you know,
like be like Canada can do no wrong,
despite the fact it's one of the most overtly racist places I've ever been to,
um,
the entire country.
You know what I mean?
But od you gotta do is put on a silly hat and take some syrup out of a fucking
tree.
And then Michael Morris just like,
oh my God,
these people are amazing.
Um,
oh,
well why would you do that?
Why,
why,
why would you have such a nice friendly podcast and then,
you know,
just have to pick on and,
punch up bill,
why can't you punch up?
So what I've learned here about Vancouver,
um,
other than it's,
it's beautiful and that they like,
they like buildings that look like the buildings that Godzilla steps on.
I've noticed that
there's a lot of,
a lot of money from China here.
You know,
I dunno what the fuck happened in China,
but some sort of crackdown happened and there was a bunch of rich Chinese people
where they were just like,
oh fuck,
we got to get our money out of this country.
And they started buying up property along sunset strip bunch of places in the
United States and evidently here in Vancouver and I gotta,
I gotta commend
mmm.
Chinese people with money.
Those people know where to fucking buy.
You know,
although I think Vancouver is smarter than La with the global warming,
without,
you know,
it's lush land up here with all the water,
lakes and everything.
It's absolutely beautiful.
Um,
I dunno,
that must be incredible to leave China and come to Vancouver.
We can actually have space,
but then it'd be weird because you'd miss,
you know,
you'd miss your country.
Right.
But,
uh,
I don't know,
just having been over there how crowded it is and how dirty the air is,
it's got to be fucking incredible because I think it's incredible.
It just coming up from La,
you know?
Um,
and there was like a million people.
All these people coming out here login,
that Goddamn skis skiing is fucking incredible.
But I got to tell you literally have to be like your own Roadie,
you know?
And there was all these people like,
you know,
you gotta go snowboard man,
you can just have that like a backpack.
Just throw it over your fucking shoulders.
Right.
It seems to be like,
I was just sort of analyzing it.
Like skiing scares the shit out of me because it's like every year,
some fucking guy around my age cheesily people my age,
you know,
late forties,
early fifties.
And they just come down a trail and they hit a tree and then then it's just
fucking it.
But the last time I skied,
I was in Utah and a doing a gig out there and the comedian I was working with
wanted to go skiing.
So we went,
I fucking dislocated my thumb and like nine times I thought it was going to blow
out my niece and I vowed I would never go again.
And if I did,
I would go snowboarding.
I would much rather deal with a broken tailbone or fucked up risks than a blown
out knee.
Um,
you know,
in my,
it's my advanced age.
Um,
so anyways,
I am going to go over to the venue right now because,
uh,
they allegedly,
they got a drum kit backstage at that place.
So I think I'm gonna go over there and go jam man on some fucking tunes.
Good,
clean fun.
And then I'm going to do my two shows and listen to this.
I come home,
I go to bed and then I have to get up at four in the morning because I have to
call.
Uh,
I got a call back east cause I got a big show coming up in Boston and I got to
sell a bunch of tickets.
So,
and they want me to come on the radio live.
And uh,
so that's going to be my day.
Something to wake up at four in the fucking morning,
do that shit and then go to the God damn airport and then come home.
And my daughter's going to be like fucking bouncing off the walls ready to play.
But you know what,
it's going to be great.
You know what's cool is she,
uh,
we have this door to our house where it's got like,
you know,
you got the door and then along both sides it has like these,
those old fashioned like little windows that go from the top all the way down to
the bottom.
So,
uh,
it's the greatest thing ever when you'd come home cause she's looking through
smiling at you.
But it's still worse when you leave.
You know,
cause she has like the saddest look on her face.
Cause now she actually understands when you're leaving.
So,
um,
and I got a feeling it's only gonna get worse.
I just don't want to get to the point where it's like I'm never want to be the
point where I leave so much that it's no big deal.
You know,
like I remember long time ago,
Danny Gans,
the late Danny Gans told a story of how we ended up in Vegas is this kid drew a
family portrait and it was the mother.
And all the kids.
And then he goes,
oh,
that's great.
Where's Daddy?
And then she pointed and she had drawn an airplane and was on the plane flying
away.
It was like,
oh,
fuck.
Um,
but what am I going to do?
This is what the fuck I do for a living.
Uh,
we also announced some dates over,
uh,
two dates,
um,
one in Dublin and one in London.
And I know I got some shit from people.
Why don't you come here?
Why don't you come there?
I'm going to do more of an extensive tour through Europe.
Uh,
at some point I just have to figure out.
I got a balanced my new life here with the wife and kid.
Um,
but I definitely want to get to places that had been before and places that I've
never been a,
I just have to figure out how to do it.
But when I go to,
um,
that Dublin in London Gig,
that's,
that's the week of my 50th birthday.
So I'm doing Dublin,
uh,
first and then I'm doing Royal Albert Hall,
which is insane.
Then I'm going to be there.
I can't believe it.
And that's going to be for my 50th birthday.
And uh,
then I'm taking a week off and I ain't going with,
you know,
my wife and kid and everything.
And that's how I'm going to celebrate turning 50 man.
What the fuck?
So
I don't know.
Most,
a lot of my friends didn't make it this far,
so I'm not going to bitch about it,
but uh,
it's a big number.
Okay.
Hey,
it's a rough one.
I right.
All right,
well that's the podcast.
Thank you guys for listening.
Thank you everybody up here in Vancouver,
they came out to the show last night and are coming tonight.
Uh,
amazing crowds last night and I think it's going to be more the same tonight.
Have a great weekend and I'll talk to you on that.
Okay.
Hey,
what's up everybody?
It's bill burr and it is the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
March the eighth,
2010.
Oh my God.
Could you believe the Oscars last night?
I can't believe that Kelly Wiggin Twat and phase didn't get best supporting
current for a,
let's make a fucking Afghan in the 18 hundreds.
Do you know,
I'm actually still in San Jose right now and I was supposed to have a show
tonight.
I'm actually recording this on Sunday.
I was supposed to have a show tonight,
but it got,
because everybody evidently is watching the fucking Oscars now.
I can understand if you're a abroad and you want to watch that shit,
I get it.
That's like your super bowl.
We get to sit there and watch the different dresses in which couple is with
which couple and who just broke up and are they there with their new boyfriend
or girlfriend and oh my God.
Did they ignore each other on the red carpet and look at some fucking twats
yanked back face as she talks about their shoes.
I get that.
But where the fuck with a men in San Jose who I,
we had the enough fucking balls left in their relationship to be like,
you know what?
I'm not going to your stupid fucking Oscar party.
Okay.
Cause I don't want to listen to fucking 98 different reads of,
Oh my God,
you know,
I'm like,
God,
why is she wearing that jazz?
Oh my God,
she looks so beautiful.
Oh my God.
That was like the best speech Aba.
Huh?
Is that what you did?
He's sitting in a cubicle right now as a man.
Is that what you did last night?
Cause if he did he should be hanging in your fucking head.
Huh?
What happened?
Let's go down memory lane.
Okay,
go all the way back to high school when you still let us set up balls between
your fucking legs.
Remember that they were brand new and they were ready to go.
I got a question for you.
Where the fuck did they go?
Cause you definitely,
you definitely didn't have them.
Men of San Jose because you weren't in my fucking show last night to the point
it had to be canceled.
Granted,
I'm not going to lie.
About a fucking month and a half ago,
a married couple came out of a bar,
got into with a bouncer.
A cop showed up and he fucking tased the dude's wife and shot the guy in the
abdomen and the dude damn near bled out right in front of the Improv here.
Look it up online.
They got the picture,
you know,
after this shooting,
they clean up the mess.
There's always the fucking,
uh,
old ketchup stains on the sidewalk and a couple of articles of clothing and it's
fucking hilarious.
And then right,
right next to it they had the marquee and it still said Eddie Griffin.
It was funny.
So yeah,
I guess that isn't good for fucking business.
But,
um,
I got to tell you,
man,
I had a great time coming up here and I've avoided coming to San Jose because I
was worried that a basic,
what happened Sunday night.
I thought it was going to happen all week because I don't know what is about
California.
I just feel like if you're not,
if you're not a fucking Latino comic,
you know,
I just don't [inaudible] super famous.
You're not going to sell any tickets out here.
Cause you know,
some people put that in my head.
Um,
but no,
a lot of people came out on a Saturday night and they actually had a balcony.
That was the thing about on Friday,
nobody showed up.
Right.
So they are amp.
I'm standing in this huge fucking theater in the entire upper deck is empty.
I felt like I was performing at a fucking royals game.
You know,
I felt like I should've been like singing the national anthem or something like
that,
and then yelling at my manager wondering what happened to my fucking music
career that I couldn't at least sing it like an angel's game.
Well,
those fucking idiots got to come out there with that.
They have there that goddamn noise makers.
How Leymah you his fans that the ownership is basically saying,
you know what?
You guys have such a lack of passion.
We need to,
we need to,
to invent something to make it sound like you guys care way more than you really
do here.
Here's a couple of inflatable fucking plastic balloons.
Just slam them together.
We'll even get a monkey will have a crazy monkey out there.
Fucking angels.
Um,
anyways,
what am I doing here?
What the fuck am I talking about?
I actually,
I had a great weekend and uh,
believe it or not,
you wouldn't know it from my voice.
And I found a great Sushi place out here at checkout.
Smile,
Sushi,
Sushi.
If you get a chance to,
I don't know where the fuck it is,
but you have the Internet,
right?
They gave me,
I'm fucking walking around right now.
I'm looking out the window.
They got a museum across the street and they have a star trek exhibition and you
should have seen these fucking nerds.
You should have seen these fucking nerds.
Just,
just,
just standing outside,
like waiting for a museum to open.
That's when you know you're a fucking nerd.
Okay?
Everybody's gone to museum.
But who the fuck has ever stood outside of museum with your face pressed against
the glass,
waiting for the fucking thing to open up.
You know,
Jesus Christ.
I mean,
I,
I see back in the day,
you're what?
You're waiting for fucking concert tickets.
You know what I mean?
Back in the day when they used to have like actually have record stores and the
artists would come through and you'd be standing outside strawberries records
and tapes,
you know,
waiting to have your cassette signed by Brian Adams.
What did I pick?
Bryan Adams.
I'll tell you why,
because I'm staying at a very nice hotel as I've made it to that level in this
business.
All right.
I am on the 14th floor,
the Penthouse fucking level,
although I just have a suite.
I haven't got to that level yet and I'm looking out the barren fucking landscape
here as far as people go.
Anyways.
Um,
but anyways,
I went down to the fucking place to have breakfast in the second I walked in.
Right?
All I see is,
is his cloth napkins in leather bound menus.
So right there,
you know,
it's going to be like 58 bucks for an Omelette.
So all I want to do is stop and turn around and get the fuck out of the place.
But do I,
of course I don't.
You know why?
Because there's so few people in there that everybody looked at me when I came
in and it reminded me of this time when I went to this titty bar in Troy,
New York,
I believe it was Troy,
New York.
It was called the cloud night.
And he perverts out there.
You know what the fuck I'm talking about?
It's not really,
it's,
it's sort of a strip club,
sort of a guy's house.
I would have to describe it as,
I just remember there was an upstairs when he came walking in that literally
look like some old lady should came down in her house coat and just been like,
all right Kenya,
Kenya,
stop all the strapping.
I'm trying to sleep.
Um,
and then some sort of double wide trailer that's sold videos that was attached
to the other side of it.
But anyways,
long story short,
I want to know what to other people who will remain nameless cause I don't name
names and the fucking podcast because I'm old school.
Um,
I can't even fucking remember who they are anyways.
I've talked to my cell phone so fucking much.
So anyways,
I walk into the God damn place.
We all walk in and the second we walk in,
all we want to do is turn around and walk out.
But there's so few fucking people in there.
Everybody's looking at us,
the dancer,
the fucking Dj,
the fucking,
uh,
porky guy who runs the God damn place.
And the two fucking,
uh,
immigrant truckers who was sitting in there,
I believe they were Yugoslavian.
I can't remember what,
see,
you know,
he just fucking go in and sit down.
So I went in and I sat down at this fucking breakfast place and back to the
breakfast place.
All right.
Try to keep up.
I'm playing these fucking brain games on the Internet.
Her right?
My fucking brain is sharp.
It's coming back.
Um,
God,
I'm lonely anyways.
Um,
so I sit down at his fucking breakfast place and uh,
there's just a medium sized woman who suffers from vocal fry.
And for those of you didn't major in communications and didn't have to take a
career speech class.
Vocal fry is basically a way of speaking where you're not,
you're not forcing enough air through your vocal chords.
So you start your talk like this.
Have you heard,
have you ever heard people talking to that?
Oh my God,
I was up at Amy's house the other day and I just felt like she was giving me
this vibe.
Or you have the other people who start off where they,
they,
they push enough air through their vocal cords.
But then towards the end they taper off.
Today everyone we're going to be reading about a lady who buy,
buy,
buy Bababa that I hit it fucking drives you nuts and never used to bug me until
I took a class on it.
Now I can't stop hearing.
So this fucking idiot is sitting there talking like the typical,
like,
I dunno,
she sounded very intelligent,
but all she was talking about was like us magazine Shit.
And meanwhile I was listening to a instrumental of a Brian Adams song over the
fucking radio.
You know,
when Brian and his first came out and he had the Fonzi leather jacket,
right.
And you're like,
wow,
this guy's good.
He's got some decent towns.
You know,
Ken mothers' feel 60 remember that?
And when he was so young,
you thought that that actually rocked,
but it wasn't bad for pop.
And then he just fucking jumped the shark where he's just like,
you know what?
I can't fucking do this anymore.
My face is breaking out.
I can't fucking do it anymore.
I'm just going to sell out.
I want to write a song for chicks.
Richard Marx can do it.
So can I,
and then he had that song.
Yeah.
Okay.
Stay
hot.
That song.
Okay.
Chair.
Yeah,
that's stupid fucking song.
They used to make receptionist tear up all across this country when it would
come on and,
and a dental office.
Um,
they had an instrumental version of that going on as I ate my fucking scrambled
eggs and listen to this fat fuck.
Talk about little house on the prairie with vocal fry.
So that was probably the low point of the weekend.
Um,
I don't even know what I'm talking about.
You know what I did want to hype,
I wanted to hype Jesus Christ.
That was only 10 minutes is no fucking way.
I'm making this one.
This one's going to be short and sweet everybody,
or shortened mediocre,
however you want to fucking call it.
Let's hit the refresh pray page.
Let's see how the Bruins and the penguins are doing.
Bruins need to win this one.
Got To make sure we make the playoffs so we can fucking lose in the first round.
Still one to one after two periods,
two friends of mine,
Billy guard,
Dell and Randy Bowman or Bauman are at the,
uh,
at the penguins game right now.
Randy Bauman from Jim and Randy showed WTV in Pittsburgh.
Have a fucking listen.
They're sitting there talking shit,
texting me,
talking shit.
You know,
right before the game about how the penguins were going to kill the Bruins.
we're having an off year and lo and behold,
you know,
an hour goes by,
there's no shit-talking.
So I go on the Internet,
there is zero zero after the first fucking period.
He's fucking asshole penguin fancy.
No,
Harry Sinden of the Bruins was actually debating suing the Pittsburgh Penguins
when they switched to black and gold for stealing the Bruins colors.
You know,
I'm going to pause here and let the people in Pittsburgh Exhale,
right?
Be like,
hey,
you fucking bitch birch too.
Freud's had been around since before the fucking stealers and the Steelers back
in the day used to basically have yellow uniforms.
They had that big stupid yellow helmet.
That's what they had.
All right.
And the only black you had was a couple little stripes.
That's all it was back then.
When you play the old 23 skidoo the long,
I say the long pass when you were doing that shit,
so I don't want to hear it.
Um,
and plus,
you know what I mean?
Who?
Who fuck takes the exact same colors as another team in the same league.
Okay.
You started off with your gay little baby blue fucking penguin.
You know,
first of all your penguins.
Why am I talking shit that I'm going to get hit with the obvious one was the
last time you guys want a cup 19 CUNY to then shut the fuck up bill.
Fine.
I will.
All right.
You just keep joy and that fucking whiny pussy.
He's not a pussy,
but have you ever seen,
I haven't seen anybody wine the way Cindy Crosby wine since fucking,
he's like Danny Ainge on skates pow of power.
Saw play fucking hockey and was a good looking guy with full ruby red lips from
Nova Scotia.
All right,
so whatever,
let's hit refresh again.
Do they at least make the end of the fucking period here?
Come on.
Berlin's.
There we go.
The end of the two.
One to one.
What do you guys say now?
They have Billy guard down.
Fucking cock sucker.
All right.
Um,
what was I trying to say here?
oh,
I know I wanted to hype is,
uh,
one of the fans here on the podcast who will also remain nameless,
um,
has started a fan page for the Monday morning podcast.
Okay.
So I'm actually going to the next level with this podcast.
Um,
a lot of times I make references and uh,
you know,
people,
don't have time to look them up or maybe you do want to go all over the internet
trying to figure out what the fuck I'm talking about.
This guy has a bunch of,
uh,
you know,
has links to some of the references.
He,
you know,
does all that Photoshop stuff.
He does all that computer stuff that I don't know how to describe,
but basically if you'd like to check it out at the end of the podcast or maybe
follow along,
you can go to a page called a www.themmpodcast.com www.themmpodcast.com.
No spaces.
Okay.
And there you go.
I'm hyping that for the week.
Um,
see,
this is why I don't hype shit now I just,
whatever flow,
I just fucking had his out the goddamn window.
What else did I do here?
You know what I like about San Jose is a,
it is actually a hockey town.
Like I'm in my hotel,
they have the NHL Channel and I was sitting there watching hockey night in
Canada,
which is Saturday night.
Um,
and I,
what the fuck was I watching?
I was watching Toronto versus Ottawa and a that had to go do my show.
But coming up they had a,
the La kings verse to Canadians with any luck,
they fucking beat him.
They beat him.
You know what I'm going to check.
God knows I've got nothing else to talk about.
On this fucking podcast.
Um,
no,
you know what,
let's continue this sports theme just so we can get rid of all the people who
aren't into sports and are into other things like politics.
The fuck is up with that and wants to deal with people who were informed.
Um,
on a number of weeks ago,
I actually,
I ripped Peyton manning a new asshole and upon listening back to it,
you know,
I actually sounded like half of fucking retard.
I will definitely admit that,
but I still stand by my opinions.
And uh,
I kept bringing up a guy by the name of Terry Bradshaw who has four Superbowl
rings and uh,
you know,
everybody hit me with dude,
you'll need to from late 20.
[inaudible]
well,
they have a great article on Terry Bradshaw in sporting news magazine this week
or this month.
I don't really read this magazine,
but I'm,
that kid from a Nebraska was on the cover that a Dum,
Dum,
Dum [inaudible] Su Damo Kong sue.
I Dunno,
he's got a great fucking name and uh,
the Patriots needed defensive tackle,
but I know we're not going to draft high enough to get that guy.
But I just wanted to read about,
cause I figured maybe they talk about other defensive tackles that were
available because I have no life.
Um,
but anyways,
I opened it up and Lo and behold,
there was a great article about Terry Bradshaw,
which basically backs up what the fuck I was talking about.
At least in my world.
It does.
And uh,
and they mentioned right in the beginning it said a Bradshaw won his fourth and
final Superbowl ring with an MVP performance for the Steelers at the rose bowl
among quarterbacks.
Only Joe Montana has that record and it's quite possibly none will ever surpass
it.
Okay.
All you Peyton manning fans out there,
do you think he's going to get five fucking rings then it'll get for,
I think you could possibly get three.
He's not getting four though.
All right.
And this is coming from fucking Terry Bradshaw,
a man who played the game.
This is what,
this is a quote from the article,
the only thing that matters in the prose is winning the super bowl.
I've never had anyone come up to me in my life and say,
hey Terri,
how many yards did you throw?
Four.
How many touchdown passes do you have?
It's all about rinks.
Does that sound familiar?
Go listen to the fucking February 8th podcast.
Maybe Terry listens to my podcast.
I'll fucking arrogant.
Is that,
um,
but then he says,
uh,
he says it's all about rings,
but do the shit that this guy took.
You know,
I knew in the beginning of his career that this guy had a rough time in
Pittsburgh and everybody,
you know,
basically treated him like a dumb redneck and uh,
kind of like what they did with John Rocker.
I always fought John Rocker,
got a bum deal because I was living in New York and they were basically calling
this guy a fucking moron,
redneck and not so many words.
And then he comes out and starts trash in New York.
And then typical media,
they get to step away like data and insight.
Any of it,
you know,
and all the mets fans get to act like they weren't fucking yelling shit at him.
I used to be doing a bit about that.
That uh,
without of the,
the,
the punchline was basically you had date rapists and wife beaters throwing
batteries at a bigot.
That was basically,
that was my little fucking social commentary on the John Rocker incident.
Let me get back to this shit.
Not Supporting anything that John Rock has said,
but you know what I mean?
It's like,
you know,
if you can gonna fuck fucking throw rocks rocks at a,
at a,
at a Hornet's nest.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
Did I almost just say you're going to get stung.
You know what I almost just created,
there was one of those southern fucking expressions that I love so much faster
and Turkey shit through a 10 horn.
I'll tell you that boy,
that boy fuck a rock up.
You thought a snake was under it.
Anybody from down south can just send me a whole list of those fucking things.
Have I already done this on the podcast and I don't remember.
I absolutely love those fucking expressions that Boyd fuck mud.
I don't even know what they mean.
That boy would fuck a rock if he thought a snake was under it.
How does that make any sense?
But,
but,
but what I love about us,
even though it doesn't make sense,
you,
you understand what the person is saying and there,
there's a genius to that.
So anyways,
um,
let me,
uh,
let,
let's read about Terry Bradshaw was the early part of his fucking career
basically.
Yeah,
they were,
they were shitting all over it.
Well,
why,
why don't we have Terry said here,
he said,
you have to understand something.
My first five years were not the best.
I had shit thrown in my face.
I was booed,
criticized,
called stupid and dumb players talking about,
we're saying this is a players on his teams were saying,
uh,
we win in spite of him.
He stutters in the huddle.
I had so much of that shit thrown at me.
I got bitter about it.
And my coach,
who I thought never defended me in public.
Chuck,
no.
Um,
the thing was,
I was never his chosen one.
I had to sit back and come to grips with all that.
And it was very painful for me.
It wasn't a storybook career.
So I take a great deal of pride and being the quarterback of the team that won
all those super bowls.
Yeah.
And the guy never gets to fucking respect.
Do you know before Superbowl 13?
Uh,
Thomas Hollywood Henderson said Terry Bradshaw couldn't spell cat if you spotted
them,
the sea and the AA.
So they asked Bradshaw about this and if you watch football,
you know,
we always comes off like this guy just being all silly and joking around.
But he goes,
well,
it ticked me off.
The thing that ticked me off was nobody defended me.
Who came out on my team and said,
bullshit.
He calls the place,
he sets it up.
Who defended me?
Chuck Noll didn't,
didn't defend me.
The only guy I know was said something was Joe Greene.
And then here I got to deal with this thing going into the Superbowl.
What the hell am I going to do?
I'm smart enough to know not to get in that argument with Hollywood Henderson
through the media because it's a distraction.
Um,
I don't have time for that shit.
Okay,
so I can't spell cat.
If you spot me the c and the t,
uh,
that's some good shit.
Congratulations.
Then you go out and you kicked their asses.
How much has my spelling look?
Now you're the one who had to go to prison.
He took it there.
Terry's an angry mother fucker or whatever.
I love it.
You know something and he never went back to Pittsburgh.
I didn't even notice that shit when he was done.
He just left.
He doesn't even talk to any of the players.
And he said,
he goes,
I mean,
it's kind of a failure of my personality.
I don't know.
It's a really interesting article because if you watch him on a,
whatever the hell this show is called,
the NFL pregame,
he still plays it up.
Like he says,
you know there's this just this country boy,
but he isn't,
he's fucking sharp as a tack and a,
he didn't like the way he was treated in Pittsburgh and I enjoy that.
I enjoy that considering those guys now,
how seriously they take their team and their fucking quarterback game four super
bowls.
He treated them like such shit.
You know,
I just liked,
I liked when teams do that to their fucking players cause it makes Boston fans
look better cause God knows where bunch of fucking assholes,
you know,
kind of like when Montreal booed Patrick was out of town.
I love bringing this shit up and then he goes out to fucking Colorado and
immediately wins the Stanley Cup and then like four years later wins another
one.
I love that now Montreal hasn't been a factor since fucking 1993 I love that
too.
It's over there.
Last dynasty was 1979 they dominated a six team league that spilled over into
the expansion six and then everybody got their shit together and you haven't
heard anything from those motherfuckers sense and they're still walking around
with their chest puffed out about some shit that they did back in the three
stooges era.
You know,
it's fucking over
30 years ago.
It's been 30 years since you guys dominated the fucking Nhl.
All right,
to get off,
you got damn high horses.
All right dad out to get me a couple of emails.
Okay,
let's continue on with the,
with the podcast here.
Um,
here's a couple of,
uh,
videos if you want to watch this one that I wanted you guys to check out.
Um,
there's a video of your van Halen Fan.
Go on Youtube and check out van Halen and it's a song and the cradle will rock.
If you just search that,
a bunch of videos will come up and click on this second video down and uh,
just look what David Lee Roth is wearing.
It's absolutely fucking hilarious.
But I'm telling you,
it's funny as it is,
there's going to be a part of you being like,
God dammit,
I wish I could get away with wearing something like that.
Can you imagine the amount of pussy I would get if I wore something like had the
balls to wear something like that.
For those of you who aren't near a fucking,
I'll basically describe it,
who aren't near a fucking computer right now.
Maybe you're on a treadmill trying to work off that Burgee aid at Carl's Jr at
two in the morning.
No one,
you shouldn't have done it.
We woke up this morning feeling like you had a fucking anchor in your stomach.
You know,
I got it.
Goes fucking sweat it off.
He's basically wearing,
um,
picture.
If you,
if you,
if you had a zoot suit made out of Spandex and all you were wearing was the
pants.
So they basically came up right underneath your fucking chest,
right?
And then you remember those,
you remember those fucking,
and they're in their purple sparkle to all right.
And then that's it.
You don't have anything else on other than,
do you remember those boots that those whores used to wear an aspen in like the
late seventies,
early eighties,
where they look like they skinned a woolly mammoth.
He has on White,
wooly,
mammoth snow boots.
And the greatest thing is the crowd is just fucking stick cause it's early on in
their career.
I don't know if it's from another country.
I have no fucking idea.
I haven't watched it in awhile,
but I was just remembering it and I wanted you guys just check it out.
Jesus Christ.
I told that fucking story in real time.
All right,
here's another one.
Another youtube video somebody sent me.
It says a checkout Dwarf midgets killer movie tie.
M U.
A.
T.
H.
A.
I this is basically it's,
it's very uh,
very accurately,
uh,
described it.
It's one guy is a dwarf and the other guy's a midget or a little person as the
new way class that they invented a little person and they are,
uh,
they're fighting somewhere.
I'm going to guess,
and maybe the Philippines and it's a Muay Thai fight and it starts off funny.
Then you think it's fake because the midget keeps hitting the dwarf with the
exact same fucking punch.
The dwarf keeps trying to kneel knee,
neither midget and the chest and the midget keeps coming with an overhand right.
And I was kept thinking,
why the fuck is he keeps [inaudible] fuck does he keep throwing the same punch?
This must be fake.
But then I realized that the boxing gloves on the midget actually go beyond his
elbow.
So he couldn't throw a hook if he wanted to.
And then after that it just becomes sad.
There's something about the dwarf space where he just really looks like he's
getting,
he's physically at paint.
The Megyn has,
you know,
he's still got that,
that,
that Christmas twinkle in his eye.
He seems like he's having a good time.
He's got a little bit of swagger in his wattle.
He's probably getting some pussy after the shelf,
you know.
And uh,
that was a good question.
Would you have a lot of Midget Bang you women out there?
I know some guys have banked a little person,
but I was just wondering,
you know,
if you just laid down on your stomach and you just felt like that,
like that.
Yeah.
At Wiggle and eight year old riding you from behind,
do you know how long your hair would have to be so you could actually pull it in
that position?
Why am I being such an asshole this week?
I don't know why.
All right.
Next,
uh,
next few to video.
I'll tell you why because I don't have a fucking show and I have a show tonight
and I'm waiting to take a red eye,
JetBlue,
back to a JFK.
I'm not looking forward to going back to New York this time of year with that
fucking weather.
I really have not missed the winter whatsoever.
That's a big thing they asked from the east coast.
Don't you miss the four seasons?
What?
Frankie Valli and those guys,
is that what you say?
Do I miss the four seasons?
No,
I don't know.
I don't,
I like it.
I like being old and being in the retirement community that is Los Angeles.
It's,
you know what La is like?
It's like a,
it's like Florida for somebody who's still middle aged,
you know you go to Florida,
does it die?
That's the last place I'll go.
Go out there and get me a gate or boat,
you know?
That's what I'm going to do.
That's how I'm going to parachute out of my life.
I'm going to
probably get a divorce and just say,
listen,
I'm cashing in my chips.
I can't do this.
We had kids all rights fucking over there out of the house.
What do we need to stare at each other for the rest of fucking time?
So I sit there,
watch and you slowly gumming those waffles that used to be able to tear through
and an English muffin in a minute and a half.
Now we sit here for fucking 37 minutes is I want you,
I don't want to live that life with you.
Okay?
We had a great time.
I give you a high five,
but I'm afraid I'm going to break his shoulder and then I'll go and then I'm
going to go down to Florida and I'm just going to get one of those fucking boats
with the fan on the back.
And I'm going to give,
I'm going to give everglade tours is they want to play some [inaudible] and some
ACDC.
I'm not going to have an affected southern accent and that's it.
Now I'm gonna live off my DVD money even though I won't exist anymore.
Um,
and I'm addressed all in khaki.
Okay,
let's continue on.
Um,
the next youtube video that you can look at is,
uh,
there's one called a public access TV hosts bombarded with prank calls,
is the name of it.
I don't know if this is the right video.
Somebody sent this one to me and I accidentally deleted it.
So I just buy him describing it.
I think this is the one,
so look it up and it's basically a guy in public access trying to talk about gun
control.
And it's such a low budget that,
you know,
it's not pre,
it's,
it's basically live and he puts his phone number up there.
So somebody calls in realized is it's,
you know,
realizes that it's live and tells him to go fuck himself.
And then the entire audience,
like a bunch of Goddamn children call in in all they're saying is just the
dirtiest shit that they can basically think of.
And of the best guys are the ones who actually start talking about gun control
for a minute.
So this guy actually feels like he's having a discussion
and right as the guy who starts to engage with them,
they tell them to go fuck himself.
So if you're an angry prick like me,
it's an I,
it's actually a a,
it's a nice one.
So with that,
um,
I have been on lumosity.com for all of last week,
uh,
trying to get my BPI score to go up,
which is,
I don't even know what the fuck it stands for.
Basically,
the higher the number you have,
the less a moron.
I Dunno,
I was going to say retarded,
but I don't like using that word.
Uh,
even though I've already said it five times his fucking podcast,
the less dumb you are I guess are the smarter you are the higher it is.
Right.
I got confused in the middle of it.
I don't know.
I'm worried about my brain right now,
everybody because a,
it's feeling fuzzy and I think a lot of it has to do with talking on my cell
phone too much and I'm trying to cut down on that like a cigarette smoker and
I've been going to this,
this website,
lumosity.com and has these,
these games that challenge your brain.
It's the fucking awesome.
And they got everything out.
Any,
any type of any type of stuff that you could be thinking of?
I don't know if I talked about this last week,
so I'll kind of blow through it.
It's Lumosity,
l u m o s I t y.com.
Somebody else else's has suggested one that was,
um,
I don't know how to read it because it's a website here.
That's all.
I don't know how to say it here.
It's,
it's www.no spaces here.
Pos,
So it's post it science pos it,
science.com.
Um,
and they have these brain games and I really think in a number of years.
That's right.
I did talk about this last week that they,
that they're basically,
instead of having all these,
these exercise shows at night that involve,
you know,
getting fucking abs and all that type of shit,
they're actually going to be selling stuff late at night.
That's going to be basically crunches for your brain.
And um,
I would recommend it.
It's kind of been my new thing that I do out here.
I told you I've been trying to learn,
learn how to write with my right hand.
I'll tell you about that shit.
I'm a lefty and somebody who's a comedian was telling you about this book that
he was reading that uh,
if you actually do things with your opposite opposite hand,
it opens up different areas of your brain.
And,
um,
so I've been doing that,
you know,
I'm writing with my right hand.
I've been throwing shit around my,
my hotel room with my left hand.
I'm kind of fucked up where I,
I kind of jump back and forth.
Play Guitar,
lefty.
I played drums,
righty.
I play sports right handed.
I write lefthanded can use tools either hand fucking rub one out with the left,
but in a pinch.
Okay,
let's plow ahead.
So this is the type of Shit I've been doing.
So I've been learning how to write with my right hand and I basically,
my handwriting with my right hand looks at,
looks like my handwriting in like fourth grade.
Um,
it looks like it if I would,
if I was in the fourth grade and um,
I just saw a ghost.
That's the way it looks.
It's looking very spooky.
But,
uh,
I've also been trying to learn how to become a better speller.
I just,
you know,
something like,
I always make fun of how the fact that I'm a fucking moron and I'm like Terry
Bradshaw,
I definitely play up my stupidity,
but there's definitely a seed of a,
or maybe some people would say a deep well of stupidity that I actually have.
And most of it,
um,
is odd.
It just laziness.
I mean,
there's no reason why I should know how to spell the word restaurant at my age.
I've been to a bunch of them and I've tried to spell it a million times.
And for the life of me,
I always forget if the u comes after the first day or the second a.
And,
um,
I've tried this a number of times and I'm gonna try to stick with it as I just,
as I,
you know,
try to type an email and rather than just hitting spellcheck and just moving on
with my life,
I'm trying to actually make a list of words.
I don't know how to sell,
sell,
spell,
see how my brain's fucked up.
Um,
and then what I do is I,
then I write,
I write the word properly,
like 10 times in a row.
Um,
but I write it with my right hand.
So I'm kind of doing two things at once and it's fucking hilarious because I
kind of left this shit out and I was just thinking of the poor cleaning lady
coming in here.
Like one of the words I was learning how to spell was penitentiary.
So I have penitentiary written like fucking 12 times in this spooky I'm writing
with my opposite hand.
How can penmanship and I just kept thinking of the shining all work and no play
makes jack a dull boy,
you know?
So,
uh,
I dunno,
trying to become a smarter human being.
Am I boring the shit out of you?
Because I think that last segment was a little boring,
but I'm into this shit man.
I'm sick of just knowing stuff about sports.
I actually,
you know what,
I'm going to Europe in two weeks and,
and I desperately do not want to come off as the typical stupid American,
at least I'm in shape.
Okay.
So I'm going to be re,
you know,
representing us nicely in that category.
The fact that I'm 41 years old and I'm still fucking and shape Jesus Christ and
was felt backwards on this chair.
I didn't understand how far away the curtains were.
I should have gone with it.
At least it would have been fucking funny.
Who see if I can lean back here.
Easy,
easy,
easy.
It's not working.
Um,
oh Jesus.
Oh Jesus.
Hang on one second.
Hello.
Okay.
Hey,
let me call you back in like 20 minutes.
Okay.
Okay,
cool.
All right.
But
um,
so anyways,
uh,
the fuck am I talking about?
I got a,
um,
I got this magazine,
Scientific American because I'm like,
I can't keep reading these fucking sports magazines.
And two,
there was a guy in there,
these egg heads when they want to,
as much as I love trash and people,
if you notice,
you know,
I just insult the way you look and I say fuck a lot,
but these guys are actually intelligent human beings and this guy was making fun
of people who tell stories.
You ever see those stories where people say they died,
I was dead for two minutes and then I came back and then they come on and they
start talking about the stuff that they saw.
But this the way this scientist guy breaks the shit down.
Scientists guide that.
I really just say that the way this dude's just shines,
dude.
Right Dwight,
he break shit down.
Um,
it's just fucking brilliant.
He basically says,
you're not dead.
You had a near death experience.
You were in a,
uh,
um,
a a near death state.
You weren't dead.
If you would dead,
you're dead.
They can't bring you back from being dead.
All right.
Even if you fucking hard stops just because your heart stops the dying process.
This guy was,
the way he broke it down,
he said it can take anywhere from a couple of minutes to a couple of hours to
occur depending on the conditions.
So even if somebody,
unless you get just fucking blown up vaporized,
even if somebody shoots you in the fucking heart,
your brain is still going to be firing synapses and whatever the fuck's.
I'm too stupid to know.
What it is,
but it still takes another couple of minutes and other stuff,
like he said,
can take up to a couple of hours.
So these fucking people who think they're dead or not dead and they're coming on
TV talking about the shit they saw,
like they,
like they were in another fucking,
I dunno universe and they weren't.
So he basically,
Deepak Chopra is to you know,
is on this Larry King show describing what's going on.
So the guy basically concludes it with this when a cause one other scientists
was actually kind of agreeing with Deepak Chopra by saying,
you know,
there's some stuff out there that we just,
science,
you know,
has no explanation for,
and this guy says,
so what?
The fact that we cannot fully explain a mystery without natural means does not
mean it requires a supernatural explanation.
It just means we don't know everything.
Such uncertainty is at the very heart of science and is what makes it such a
challenging enterprise.
And in that moment there was a clap of thunder and I realized that science is
religion for intelligent people.
This guy isn't saying that.
There's no god,
but he's also not listening to some guy half naked dancing around a fucking fire
with a chicken foot.
You know what I mean?
So I think that's what I think.
I think science is religion for intelligent people.
And I think religion and a lot of ways is science for morons.
Whenever they can't explain something,
they invent stories of people having,
you know,
all you can eat fish coming out of a wicker basket or fucking,
you got to have faith.
You got to have faith.
It's a fucking cop out.
You know,
if you went to go buy a fucking car and you go,
all right,
let me let the car wouldn't start up.
Don't worry.
One of these days that engine's coming back and it's going to be mad and it's
going to be judging you.
It's ridiculous.
You know?
Geez,
I don't want to get off on this fucking ramp,
but definitely check it out,
man.
If you want to read some cool stuff,
it's called scientific American.
And uh,
I dunno,
I'm kind of on this mission to,
I'm sick of being a moron.
It been,
you know,
I'm sick of being fucking stupid.
I really am.
Um,
so anyways,
let's get to,
uh,
let's get to underrated overrated.
Um,
what are we 38 minutes then look at me.
I've really could fucking run my mouth when I want to before I get into
underrated.
Overrated.
I gotta read this one and I'm going to need some help from you guys on this.
Um,
listen to this one.
Uh,
this is from some dude.
I believe he's in Italy and he said,
um,
I kill women's Libidos for a living.
All right,
here we go.
Fucking strap yourselves in for this one.
Hey Bill,
I just got out of my second of my two longterm relationships,
three plus years,
both of which eerily started and ended the same.
Uh,
both of these girls were well above average in their sexual enlightenment when
we started dating.
I'm not saying they were super freaks,
but the kind of girls that have a porno collection that can rival most guys and
the toys to match.
Also the kind of girls that while you're home visiting your parents for the
holidays,
we'll want to sneak away from the dinner table and fucking the bathroom.
Okay.
Anyways.
Um,
it seems that the standards for most of these relations,
the standard for most relationship is that you fuck like rabbits during the
first year.
If you manage to make it past the one year mark,
there is an exponential decay in the pussy rationing until you get married or
have kids at which time you're pretty much done with the sex except for
birthdays and the anniversary.
However,
the sex and these two relationships kept going strong through the second year,
at which point it completely dropped off.
And I'm not just,
I don't know.
Not Kidding,
Jay,
I'm talking just done.
I had to pull out every trick in the book just to get a sympathy fucking once
every couple of weeks.
Um,
I'm in a committed relationship and love these girls.
I guess you were in a committed relationship and you love these girls,
so I guess you didn't fuck around.
All right.
Um,
and love these girls enough to put up with the bullshit with the idea that we'll
be able to work through the issue and get back on track.
However,
as I learned,
once the pussy is boarded up,
it's out of business for good.
It's like those fucking horrific strip malls that have been abandoned since the
80s when whatever shit,
boom economy in the area made those fucking people think they were going to go
somewhere.
So inevitably when these relationships and I end up,
uh,
I get red,
my,
my fucking straight a report card on how much I'm such a great guy and I'm love
so much and they don't want to lose me as a part of their lives,
but they're just not sexually attracted to me anymore.
And that is the fucking [inaudible] and this is the best fucking part.
They don't know why.
They don't know why they're not sexually attracted to me anymore and really wish
they could change it seriously.
What the fuck no man wants to admit to himself,
let alone an audience that he's not getting alone,
that he's not getting,
that he's not getting it done.
Between the sheets.
However,
I can honestly say that I do.
All right.
I'm no fucking Ron Jeremy,
but I get the job done.
I would understand the plight of these women if I was a for blasting them.
I don't know what that means.
What does that mean?
Just jumping on him like an 18 year old pounding away or wanting to do the same
shit over and over again.
But I usually make a pretty good damn effort to make sure things stay fun in the
bedroom.
All right.
Okay.
Last two fucking paragraphs.
Uh,
let me just,
let me just a paraphrase is he basically says that he's like a William h Macy's
character in the cooler.
Um,
and he's saying that he's getting really bitter and he wants to go out right now
and go meet a woman,
fuck the shit out of her for three months,
and then give her the same speech that just happened to him.
Um,
all right.
Okay.
First of all,
don't do that.
Don't deliberately go out and hurt somebody because you dated two people who
hurt you.
That's just,
it's,
it's bad.
They don't deserve it.
They didn't hurt you.
So don't do that.
All right.
Um,
I,
I don't know what,
I mean,
I'd have to have more details of what the fuck's going on,
but I will tell you this from experience.
I know a lot of people,
they get into a relationship with somebody and that it doesn't go right.
They find out that it's not what they're looking for.
And then they go out and then they immediately basically start dating the same
person again.
It's not literally the same person,
but it's basically,
you know,
like,
just to make it simple,
if a woman went out and was dating,
met some guy at a fucking truck stop and he turns out to be an asshole.
He's driving a truck,
fucking a bunch of other women around the country.
She goes,
I'll never fucking get with a piece of shit like that again.
And where did she go?
She goes right back down to the truck stop,
which is the same gene pool of fucking people.
And I think it's very interesting that you met two girls who seemed like they
were the exact same right down to when they want it to stop fucking you.
And I got to admit,
okay,
I guess a woman having a porn collection is healthy on some level,
but that,
you know,
I don't know as far as like a girl you're going to marry,
it's like you want your girl,
it's that fine line.
You want them to fuck your brains out,
but do you really want to bang,
have them want to fuck you and your parents house?
I mean,
I dunno dude.
I'm,
I mean,
I,
I what I,
what I would guess is I would,
I would start fishing in a different lake.
It sounds to me like you,
you're a fucking God damn trout again.
Can't fucking believe it.
You know,
go out in the ocean,
you'll catch something else.
You know what I'm saying?
I think he got the same person again.
I mean,
but I mean,
I would literally have to fucking be knowing what you're doing in the bedroom,
which I don't want to know.
Um,
well,
what about you?
Do you start taking,
I guess you said you don't take her off cause that's another thing that happens
in relationships.
You know,
there's like,
you know,
big thing with women as they like kissing and uh,
guys are very focused on the,
on,
on the finish line,
the goal.
So you know,
you're getting that relationship like we haven't had sex in a while.
You want to have sex when he stuck getting in that fucking thing it,
you know,
and you just start scheduling it.
I see.
How does your day look?
Maybe around four.
Okay.
We will fuck it for,
you know,
and then you know,
you're not even self conscious so there's no excitement.
You just fucking take your clothes off.
Like you're getting stripped,
searched on your way to serving time at fucking,
uh,
some penitentiary,
penitentiary,
p e n I t and t I a r y penitentiary.
Sorry,
it's one of the words I learned this week and I was trying to remember Rikers
island and I couldn't at that point.
So dude,
I don't know what to tell you.
The bottom line.
I don't give a fuck who you are,
how I'm in love.
You are with somebody.
After a while you're going to get sick of fucking them.
That's what happens.
Um,
I dunno,
I dunno what's going on.
I don't know if you have some sort of like delayed halitosis where for the first
two years you have wonderful breath and then all of a sudden it's unbearable.
I'm just fucking with you.
I don't wanna give you a complex,
but I'm just saying,
I don't know what I would try to,
to,
uh,
meet girls in a different place.
I would start with that.
And um,
I dunno.
I Dunno dude.
This one is beyond me.
I've never,
uh,
I mean,
part of me wants to say you'd be,
you're being a little too hard on yourself here.
Uh,
but whatever,
go out there and,
uh,
you know,
go bang some fucking women.
You're single.
Go out there banks and fuck a woman.
And as always,
always talk to women that you think are Rati eleague always do that shit.
The worst thing they can do is say no,
but one of them is going to fucking say yes and that'll give you more confidence
and you'll keep moving up the draft board.
Next thing you know,
you pull in pussy out of the first round rather than drafting like you're
fucking won the Superbowl last year.
You know,
having that 28th pick,
praying that the female version of fucking Dan Marino is still around.
That didn't make sense.
But you know what I'm saying.
Um,
anyways,
am I almost done here?
46 minutes in 46 minutes into the podcast.
Let's wrap this shit up here.
People with a little bit underrated.
Overrated.
Shall we underrated a bill.
Last week you got an email from a fan that recounted,
uh,
his sister's Wiccan wedding.
Personally,
I think the ritual was that was discussed in the wedding.
His fucking mind numbingly insane,
but pardon me.
Has to give it up to the couple that got married.
I'll,
sorry.
Underrated as a having balls.
Um,
they knew their ritual would,
would not be well received,
but they did not give a fuck.
It was their day and they had the conviction to do what they wanted,
even knowing that their family and guests would not warmly receive the whole
jibberish chanting and bloodletting.
Okay.
So there you go.
Having the balls to a fucking annoy everyone in your family.
Um,
another quick thing,
a hit,
some people are traveling to Boston.
They know that I grew up there and I also fucking travel around the country and
this guy said,
hey bill,
I'm going there with my wife.
She used to,
she used to live there,
but I would also,
uh,
you know,
so she knows where to go.
I'd like to know,
you know,
have you tell me where to fuck the,
I'm paraphrasing,
obviously.
Um,
I haven't lived there since 1995 too.
So,
um,
I'm going to try to tell you to go to some of my favorite place because from
back in the day,
I would start,
go to Kathy's liquors on route one in Saugus right before,
you know,
get a good six pack and yet maybe some Michelob and then,
uh,
go up to the,
go up to the cow loon,
gets some fucking Chinese food.
Then of course,
another great liquor store out in,
uh,
out in the Boston areas out in Brockton,
Massachusetts.
Go to Blanchard's liquor store.
I'll buy the West Gate Mall.
You might want to check if that's still there,
but I know the bowling alley is,
that's a great place.
You know,
go out there and put on some flock of seagulls and try to talk to some chick
with way too much.
Uh,
who drew a triangle of pink on both of her cheeks?
I'm,
I'm just fucking with you.
The penalty.
Go to a Bruins game.
Go and stop by the penalty box.
That's a good bar.
It's really alcohol based.
Stay away from the freedom trail.
Okay.
I don't know about you guys,
but there's nothing more boring to me anyways.
Then the a revolutionary war.
It is mind numbingly boring.
Uh,
with the old weaponry.
It's like,
you know,
it's like the original Atari after you saw this playstation shit we've been
doing for the last,
you know,
50 years.
So all you hear that shit.
Does she sing it again?
Okay.
Wait a second.
Wait for it.
Not a fucking guy in the violin.
Yeah.
Can you hear it?
You probably can't fucking hear.
All right.
Um,
oh,
when somebody sent me something,
and this is the last thing I'll tell you guys before I'll,
I'll tell you all they have a good fucking week as I always do.
Try and to enter on a nice positive note.
Uh,
hey,
let me hit refresh here just to see who won this foods one in this fucking game.
Come on,
refresh
Jesus Christ.
He isn't it unbelievable how quickly your fucking computer gets old.
It's like cool for the first fucking week.
And then you download a couple of things and then it's like,
you know,
it's like Brad Pitt at the beginning of that movie where he played the old baby.
Anybody see that movie?
I don't think I've ever laughed so fucking hard and my life.
And when that guy came in and he was trying to get some pussy and he hears and
he looks down,
it was that little old baby.
You want to talk about killing a fucking woman's,
a guy's libido.
The fuck is going on with my computer.
I didn't have the thing.
I actually have dial up right now if you can believe it.
That's probably another one of the problems out right here we go.
Come on.
You fucking cunts.
Two to one.
Pittsburg eight Oh four left.
I like it though.
I forget the name of the guy,
but we have a new defenseman.
Maybe that'll help us to make up for the fact that we don't have Phil Kessel
anymore,
even though for some reason a lot of people don't like him.
So anyways,
this guy,
something,
this last thing,
I'll read you guys.
This guy sent me something about,
uh,
you know I was talking about when you go into go buy things and people asked for
your phone number and all this fucking information and if fucking creeps me out
every time they do that,
I just think that they should play in the beginning of that iron main song,
the prisoner,
he remember that from the eighties do you remember how that thing went?
You remember this?
The new number two?
What was number one?
You are number six most cycle left ever.
Can you imagine if your fucking dad would laugh at you like that back in the
day?
Be like,
son,
how many beers did you have the night?
You're just like,
I just had to,
all right and is fucking Dallas and the lights start dimming.
It's going to be over.
So anyways,
this fucking guy.
Does that make any sense by the way?
I don't know.
I'm fucking sitting here with one microphone.
No headphones in a fucking hotel room.
This is what you get.
All right,
so this guy said,
Bill,
can you believe how much fucking information people are willing to give away?
For No to strangers for no reason.
He goes,
I got my hair cut the other day and the first thing they say to me before hello,
or what can I do for you is the first thing out of the gate is what's your phone
number?
So I say,
why do you need my phone number?
She says,
so we know who you are when you come in.
Which is bullshit because they don't know you when you come in.
They still have to ask what your God damn number is.
C,
he got to love someone who actually fucking uses their brain.
So anyway,
she goes,
he says,
I don't want to give you my number.
So then she scoffs in his face and says,
we don't send the information out to anyone.
It's just to keep track of you here.
That's it.
Um,
and then she says,
uh,
then okay,
then the guy says,
he,
the guy written,
wrote this really badly here.
So then I guess he responds to,
that doesn't make me feel any better.
You don't need my phone number to cut my hair.
Then this slag does this fine.
Whatever that sounded exactly like your exaggerated impression of a dumb broad.
Then she goes,
how about your address too?
This is fucking,
you know what all these corporations are sharing this information to figure out
exactly what you buy when you buy it,
what you liked the best.
So they can just fucking,
I don't know what,
you know,
Jack,
the prices of the shit up.
So anyways,
um,
she goes,
how about your address?
And the guy goes,
what are you going to do?
Drop the hair,
cut off at my house.
Just cut my fucking,
uh,
now there's three people in line behind me in this worthless tub of come.
Jesus leans around me and says,
and says,
I guess to the people behind them,
sorry,
this takes longer.
When they,
then he writes,
they,
you know,
don't give any information.
And then he says sarcastically.
Oh,
I see.
I'm the one compliment a complicating this transaction.
And it's not even her fault.
It's her.
Oh.
And it's not even her fault.
It's her corporate creep bosses and all the fucking sheep that let people do
whatever they want.
Sorry,
this is so long.
Well,
you should apologize to my listeners because they had to listen to me read it.
Yeah,
man,
don't give those people your fucking phone numbers.
Don't give him your address.
I do.
That can,
can we get your phone number?
I had.
No,
you can't.
We're not going to do anything with it.
I,
that's fine.
That's fine.
I know you're not going to do anything with it.
I don't want you to have my phone number.
What do you call me up and see how my fucking hair cuts going?
Is it still short and you think you need an adjustment?
Did I tell you that story?
But when I went into cvs and that guy who looked at what the peewee Herman
Haircut,
there was two,
two foreigners in front of me,
they barely spoke English and they asked if they wanted one of those savings
save cards.
And they said no.
And he goes,
all right,
I'll just scan one anyways.
And he scans it.
So I walk up and I'm ready for this guy.
He goes,
do you have our little savy saved card?
And I say,
no,
I don't.
And he goes,
well,
I'll just scan it anyways and I got,
no,
I don't want you to do.
And then he scanned it and I said,
I said,
excuse me,
what did I just say to you?
I just said,
I don't want that.
And you scanned it anyways.
Why did you just do that?
And he goes,
it's all right.
I'll let it scan it and let and scan it.
And I go,
well,
what do you get?
Like half a cent for every person that you get.
You know
that,
that you get on the fucking list there.
And he goes,
no,
I don't.
It's like,
really?
Is that why you can't make eye contact with me?
You fucking piece of shit.
He probably didn't even on scan the God damn thing.
You know?
I don't understand people that help out corporations.
I just don't,
have they done anything to demonstrate that they give a flying fuck about you or
the drinking water in your town?
Don't help those cons.
I mean you can if you want to,
but that's just,
I would just,
I think it would be a better world if these fucking pricks did know every God
damn thing about you.
You know,
pretty soon you're going to walk in there and they're going to fucking asked if
you can put a,
uh,
did they can just bug you like gene Hackman in the conversation.
Right.
All right,
do it.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
You know what?
I'm going to go down and listen to this lady singer songs so I don't have to
think there's a nice little crowd down there.
Has got to be at least 26 people down there,
which I think in downtown San Jose actually constitutes a mob.
Maybe somebody will get tased and shot in the abdomen.
I don't know what.
All right,
that's the podcast for this week.
Thank you guys so much for listening.
I am in currently revamping my website and I hope that everything's going to be
up to speed.
I recently went over,
uh,
10,000 people on my mailing list,
so I'm really excited about that.
And if you want to know what's going on,
you know,
especially like if you see,
when I switched over to a lipsin with the podcast and all that fucking shit,
if you were out of the loop,
it's cause you weren't on my mailing list.
I'm not sure.
You know how funny is this?
How funny is this?
I how fucking hypocritical of mine.
I just said don't give you phone number out to these.
And now here I am asking for your web address.
[inaudible].